[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in mike floria pro football
talk live co-host
mike we are proposing overtime during
the regular season what do you think old
school
pre-1974 that's how it used to be
ties do you like ties i don't like ties
i and i guess it's on the two teams
involved to make sure there isn't a tie
and with so much more scoring now in the
two-point conversion
it's easier to avoid a tie than it would
have been back in the early 70s and
prior to that
i and dan you're on to something in this
respect
i believe that this push to go back to
true sudden death over time with this
spot and choose concept which i actually
am intrigued by
okay explain that though mike okay so
this is just proposed
of a new a new overtime uh possibility
a new overtime possibility proposed by
the ravens there's two
types there's a sudden death and there's
a straight seven and a half minutes i'm
told bill belichick prefers that seven
and a half minutes of football
whatever the score is at the end that's
the final score win lose or draw
spot and choose means in lieu of a of a
coin flip to determine first possession
one team picks where the first drive
begins for example
our own 20 yard line the the minus 20
as the football people call it your own
20-yard line
one team picks the spot and the other
team
says whether they're gonna take the ball
and play offense or give the other team
the ball and play defense
it's as equitable as it can be it's as
fair as it can be it reminds me the old
sesame street sketch where
you know you share a cookie by one
person breaks it in half and the other
one chooses which half they want
totally fair and i think it adds layers
and levels of strategy
that will probably drive coaches and
analytics departments crazy
but it's so much better if you're going
to go back to true sudden death
it's so much better than the coin flip
now the two ways the ravens are
proposing it
sudden death with up to 10 minutes or
this belichick
preferred seven and a half minutes
play that full amount and whoever's
ahead at the end
wins which which creates i think an
additional strategic
angle if you've only got seven and a
half minutes
you want to make sure that you have
enough time to do something with the
ball
when you get it back so it's just layers
and levels of strategy
that i think would drive coaches crazy
but i think it would be
fair to both teams could i have you
start on the one-yard line
well you could pick the one-yard line
but then then the other then the other
team gets to choose whether to be
offensive okay that's the beauty of it
okay
okay and and i'm told dan that the
analytics people
are viewing the 13 the minus 13 as the
break-even point that
if the the team that picks the yard
position says 12
or less then that's when you're likely
to choose to play defense
14 or more you're likely to choose
offense in the standard case
but think about it your quarterback how
you feel about your defense how
how do you feel about whatever plays you
have left in in your game plan for the
day how you feel about your kicker what
the weather conditions are so many
things are going to go into that
decision are they voting on this
i know it's just a proposal does it get
put up for vote
well they're presenting it to the
competition committee to try to get them
on board with it it has more heft
has more weight if the competition
committee is behind it but
but the most important person to have
behind it
is the commissioner and my understanding
is the commissioner
likes it because number one it makes the
game shorter and this gets back to the
point you're making with an overtime i
think they want the games to be shorter
dan not for
this year but i think it's some year
down the road
four five six whenever they're gonna
start dropping
games into more standalone windows and
this tuesday night football that we saw
a couple of times this year
wednesday afternoon at three o'clock
they're going to get creative about
having more stand-alone games because as
gambling proliferates and as
real-time in-game betting becomes
technologically available where you can
sit at home with your phone
and what you see at the stadium is
what's coming
into your home at that moment so there's
no latency
it it makes more sense to have not
nine games being played at once as many
games as possible
that are the only game where everyone's
watching everyone's engaged and
everyone's betting one play at a time on
those games
so you make the game shorter here's why
you make the game shorter because you're
going to have teams that are playing
on a five-day break four-day break
six-day break
you can't be playing for 70 minutes so i
think that's why they want to make the
game shorter so your idea from that
perspective
is brilliant thank you because every
game is capped at 60 minutes
could you propose that i don't i don't
have the commissioner's ear
could you you think i do oh you don't
either
no no but but but but he i'm sure he
would not
turn up his nose at a good idea i just
think that
that the idea of going back to ti we
just have to we'd have to accept
ties and but the strategy of a tie in
the fourth quarter
like imagine that now it changes your
philosophy of what you're doing instead
of
how many times well they're playing for
overtime now you can't play for overtime
nobody's taking a knee
now you actually are saying are we
comfortable with the tie against this
team
or do we want to go for a win or or you
know go for one versus go for two
that yeah when when overtime was the
rule
pre-74 you didn't have that option that
that see that's the beauty of it i think
and here's where i think they're on to
something the way the game is today
i think that there would be fewer ties
and that and that with all the analytics
and the in the the strategy and going
for two and
all the different things you can do i
just think that you would see less just
kind of shrugging i think they just used
to shrug at a tie yeah it's a tie okay
we'll get them next week i think it
would be far different if that were the
case now
all right a couple things i know we're
short on time uh the roughing the passer
reviewable that's that's being proposed
correct yes and i don't like it i don't
like it one bit
the reason i don't like it is 2019 pass
interference replay review
calls and non-calls the standard kept
changing
you can watch the available angles and
you can see a glancing blow and if it's
frame by frame is that forcible
contact with the head of the quarterback
i don't like it and think about dan
every interception what's going to be
part of the replay review hey was there
contact with the quarterback
was it possibly roughing the pass or i i
like the concept
but i don't like the execution that it
likely would entail because we saw it
two
years ago and what a disaster past
interference was i continue to be a
believer and the ravens are proposing
this as well
the booth umpire the the extra member of
the crew
who sees what we see at home and can
talk directly to the referee
and say drop a flag pick up a flag you
guys are making a mistake no different
than another member of the crew who runs
up and talks to the referee
and they pick up a flag that's what they
need
and they've been reluctant to do it but
i think that's the key
because what you see when you're on the
field and what you see at home
are two very different things they need
a referee an official
who sees what we see at home and can
talk to the people on the field
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host of course is a website
profitballtalk.com the fumbling the ball
out of the end zone clark hunt the owner
of the chiefs the team that benefited
from that rule in the division around
the playoffs suggested before the super
bowl that that rule would be looked at
by the competition committee there's no
proposal yet
okay on that rule and i dan i just don't
think they're going to change it
it's always been there you know once
upon a time the rule was if you threw an
incomplete pass
into the end zone and it hit the turf it
was a touch back and the defense got the
ball at its own 20.
there's just been this sacred treatment
of the end zone and that's where this
comes from as unfair as it is here's the
reality it's
fair in that it affects both teams
equally
and you know it may screw you in one
game
and you may benefit from it another game
the thing i don't like about it though
it penalizes effort and you see a guy
making maximum effort to reach the ball
out to the pylon
and if the ball slips out of his hands
and just goes out of the end zone one
inch in
you lose the ball if it goes out short
of the end zone by an inch you keep the
ball
if it hits that pylon you lose the ball
that's what i don't like about it how
about we extend the end zone
like cfl yeah
that huh that that that would that that
would make
well you know what you'd have to do you
have to go back and rebuild half the
stadium
yeah that would be the problem i'm all
in i'm good with that too
help the economy get create some jobs
there
uh anything new let me uh roethlisberger
re-signing
felt like he had to fall on his own
sword to uh take les to stay there but
uh your your thoughts when
roethlisberger announced he was coming
back
general business advice for anyone out
there who's ever negotiating a salary
with his or her employer once you say
i don't care how much get paid this year
yes
you can't take that back dan and once he
said that
he's not getting 19 million this year
the question is what's he getting that's
why it took so long
if he's getting 19 million this year
it's a half hour negotiation to figure
out
how they're going to move the money
around and reduce his cap number once he
said that
he's getting squeezed and i'm surprised
he only got squeezed for five million
dollars so
it gives them some cap space i i just i
think they're delusional
in thinking that they've got a
championship team this isn't 2005 jerome
bettis let's come back for one more run
and go win a super bowl there are some
great teams in the afc and yeah they
were 11-0 last year
eight of those games could have gone
either way i also wondered about deshawn
watson the timing of
when if you're going to trade him when
do you trade him
and i thought you know i i just have a
for sale sign
or you know like a yard sale i'd just
say come on in give me your offers like
detroit did
but i'm wondering is he more likely to
get traded closer to the draft does that
make more sense
uh but i don't even know if we're there
yet but uh what do you think about
if he is traded what the timing would be
for that
dan i think with all these teams that
are looking for quarterbacks evaluating
their options the problem
is if you wait until the draft to trade
deshaun watson
there are teams that will have made
other plans at quarterback and then
they're not at the table
and that could be a team that helps
drive another team
up to a higher price you know john
mcclane of the houston chronicle
echoed something that we had said a few
weeks ago they should get the jets and
the dolphins in a bidding war
do it now and and hey if you don't trade
for him
you're gonna have to deal with him twice
per year and play them against each
other
you know russell wilson's agent very
artfully got it out there the four teams
that he'd be willing to accept a trade
to
at some point the texans need to find
out where are the places deshawn watson
would play
let's get those teams at the table and
let but
first they have to come to the
conclusion that they're even going to do
it i feel like
at this point they are in the the i
don't know anger denial bargaining
depression acceptance they're probably
still in the denial phase
and and they just refuse they refuse to
accept the fact that this guy is never
going to play for them again and dan
have you seen or heard
anything that contradicts the prevailing
notion
that he's never putting that blue helmet
on his head again no
no and i that's why i didn't understand
why they just didn't say come on in
compete against each other and hopefully
we'll get an even
bigger treasure trove here the russell
will there it doesn't feel like there's
any real news on the russell wilson
front we're trying to make news
um you know uh i i guess his agent said
or somebody said uh this is
the reason why he likes the bears that
doesn't mean he's getting traded because
he likes matt and aggie in the offensive
line here but
um i haven't heard anything more
internally about this situation so did
russ accomplish
what he wanted to accomplish when he
came on our show well
well and let's think about the timeline
the stuff he said on your show
was jarrah and i've never heard a
quarterback talk that candidly about his
situation i think tom brady's to blame
or credit for all of that because these
guys see what happened with brady they
want to flex their muscles
that was great but then it got quiet for
a couple of weeks
so you kind of start thinking well maybe
they've worked things out well then
comes the athletic article
that that pulls some scabs off of the
situation
mark rogers says what he says on the
record which was as
jarring as the comments russell wilson
made and now it's quiet again
just because it's quiet doesn't mean
nothing's happening
i mean seahawks uh have to be
considering
their options and the four teams are
identified by rogers raiders bears
saints cowboys how do you not at a
minimum
get all the the decision makers together
and say
what what would we be willing to do here
and i've said this about the saints dan
when you look at the cap mess that
they're in and the guys that they're
going to have to part ways with
how do you not call the seahawks and say
just tell us who you want
because there's a chance they want some
guys that you're going to cut anyway
or maybe they want a guy that you're on
the fence about
so you can trade him and keep one of the
guys that you're thinking about cutting
so
i just think that that russell wilson is
good enough that those four teams need
to at least
at least explore it even if it means
calling up the seahawks and saying
tell us what you want and we'll see if
we can come close because russ can't
have his feelings hurt if you
reach out to the saints whereas deshaun
watson
you know maybe that's different or some
of these other teams where they reach
out and you go oh
gosh don't let him find out that you
reached out russ's people will
probably go okay like you have to do
your due diligence if i'm
i just find out like i i just want to
know
if it if it gets worse then at least i
know
hey you know what the saints will give
us this hey you know what the bears will
give us is this
put those two pit those two against each
other and let's see what we have here
here's what it comes down to and this
was my takeaway after
reading the item in the athletic russell
wilson views himself as patrick mahomes
and he has every right to view that we
haven't seen him
in a situation where he is a patrick
mahomes where the offense runs through
him
and it's orchestrated to get the most
out of his abilities that's what he
wants
if the seahawks don't view russell
wilson
the way russell wilson views russell
wilson then trade him to a team that
does
because necessarily whatever that team
offers
will reflect what they think of russell
wilson and the seahawks will look at and
say
these these bastards are crazy why are
they offering this for this guy
let's take it low take it and run have a
great weekend mike
always great to talk to you buddy thank
you thanks dan mike florio pro football
talk